that was American sign language we just
showed a secret message nope it wasn't
at all not even a little bit I'm here
with hey hey how's it going my name is
Hank green nailed it so far everything
has been true how are you feeling I'm
just trying not to lie ok Hank is in
town for VidCon and we just recorded an
episode of his podcast called dear Hank
and John John's not there instead we
have grace yes I did a really great John
impersonation I think it was really
great we had a good time yeah I enjoyed
watching grace get a little too deep
well it was it's seriously the complete
opposite of my Sean mentioned death like
five times yeah friendly reminder we're
all gonna die someday so like and
subscribe everyone you know will die on
that note let's play a game
I just really have this desire to see
Hank impersonate youtubers so we are
playing heads up game heads up Challenge
game bags up to the heads up challenge
game quick yeah it's that it's that app
where words come up on the screen and
you have to act out the words to the
person holding it and if it gets right
you go like this and it switches to the
next one and I have youtubers in this
game Diane has so wonderfully created a
deck of youtubers specifically so we can
play I have this thing I've made a word
I want it I want it everyone to agree
that this is a word and I figure this is
going to be my large my biggest possible
platform I get when you think you're
gonna poop but you fart instead of being
a shark it's a fool a fool which is good
because it's kind of the noise it makes
I was thinking because I got to do an
episode of your podcast and you didn't
get to do mine but the winner will get
to tweet anything they want from the
other person's account which is yeah
like it let the guests usually get on my
podcast to compete against each other in
this game we need an unbiased judge
judge Chester you go very accurate shirt
Thank You bear why do we have to have a
judge what are you doing he's holding it
on his head like this because I could
very well try to not guess all right
that you're saying if you're gonna go
with him that I minded one day this
isn't fair at all because you two know
each other far better than I know either
of you
wait was yeah oh no that was constipated
recently and I was whooping so much when
you said that I was like yeah I just
went through that sorry about it you
guys already have so much more in common
okay I'm gonna go first
are you drawing as many as I can't look
one minute what's happening uh where's
uh prayers it's me games okay bye well
that's the whole time Gibby bye what are
you okay do you want to do dick Russian
hacker do you wanna do the beatboxing
that one oh this all the basic [ __ ]
you doing you're like reticent yeah what
else does they do other than being
fabulous um oh yeah this you yeah you
know I don't think that Jeff Susie knows
anything about me anymore oh yeah so I
only got two I'm technically I think you
guys are the wrong person uh-huh
um yo what's up throw food that each
other then no food boys out some here so
you're cute you're cute right
Emma would Pokemon photo come bad you
can do all the way to the beginning I
mean you know these people are
electrical but Evan I swiped incorrectly
I'm still trying to get that last one oh
that was your warmup here's the real man
hey girl
as where to look no trick I'm awesome
that's the easiest possible thing to
start this cute and sorry um three
stroke so if anything we've learned that
this game requires a strong shield
against such a deep level of anxiety
Hank thank you for being here oh my game
Jesse you're sure thank you for judging
sighs I'm let you guys do your end card
here thank everyone out there for
judging as well just errands for judging
yourself judging us judging each other
judging yes being judgmental and what a
delightful feeling it is I think that's
why I like to make all of my guests feel
when they come into videos with me
technically you did win I'll check is it
I won I can tweet whatever for your
phone oh my god you know what
going to be gracious winner because you
have been full of such anxiety that I'm
gonna let you tweet whatever you want
from my phone to not gonna do mine it's
too much anxiety I like that you put in
your passcode like it's your phone that
two times while you were tweeting I will
tell them to go listen to the podcasts
that we recorded also just go check out
the vlog brothers and sideshow and um
the others you tweeted it Rudin okay can
I see it all caps hell up you be Oberst
it's Gilbert I moved to Grace's phone
pennies are mad
mostly I'm saying that's adorable you
guys should follow hang on snapchat
because he has a dragon named Gilbert
that takes over his name's Gilbert yo
Bart I'm sorry I am from Jersey it's my
accent apparently he's doing a Twitter
takeover on my account right now hey
thank you for being here so I don't be
with such anxiety I'll give you a Red
Bull for the way out come on
see you guys next time I don't know so
we're gonna go against each other
Lizzie sorry never had you you head
waiting it it's good American sideline